okay so this is thank you and it's like
you two are married
alright so this is an episode about a
snow golem as it was called and these
fiery dogs their firewall zoomy great
design I love the idea of these things
can just set themselves ablaze and go
out like I thought was really cool uh
and this is a side story going on while
the main story is actually just going on
the background it's Finn and Jake just
fighting the Ice King over sandwiches
and you just give this whole story about
this votes no goblins count like this
bomb little snowman and he comes across
these firewalls obviously you know Fire
and Ice they're not gonna get along and
so pretty much you got he comes across
this little puppy won this may be one
like this obnoxious little kitten right
here who'll and now it's the others shot
is a little camera whore yeah come on
Todd hey guy think a tank comes H as a
soup and yeah it's just their connection
together and it's all done in in
silencers little to no dialogue in it
and at the very end the family brings
the puppy bag and they blazed with the
snow golem and the ice king says we can
all learn something from those
sandwiches and then Finn kisses the ice
king and he says thank you and it was
both really odd and funny and strangely
kind of touching so this cat is not
gonna go away what do you want what do
you that's what I want so okay so so
yeah pretty much
I'm not gonna go big time into like oh
my god they did the whole thing in
silence because lots of movies
josè have done that and it's impressive
but people always talk about like this
is the first one to ever do it but it is
in an 11-minute format I somehow know
like there's I mean I do love these guys
stories honestly and I can't explain
what it is maybe it just gives the world
a little bit more of a dimension or
reality when you see just other
characters and creatures are not the
main characters just going off and
living their lives and telling sort of
an interesting story um you know and the
connection between the you know the
there's no golem in the little puppy I
mean it works and you get the connection
and you see some of the sacrifice he'll
make to give back to his family and I
store ease like this up I love these
guys stories you know it said I like the
Snowman that that famous short film
there anything about just like it
especially if it's silent I like stuff
that creates a lot of atmosphere and
doesn't need dialogue if it doesn't need
to in the words are great don't get me
wrong this is nothing but words but yeah
I like something that can just be like
hey let's antha communicate not the
traditional way through dialogue with
Sam communicate a different way and
still form a connection and stuff and
yeah I really liked it
yeah I don't know it's gonna try to be
silent but man oh man um no actually I
agree I thought it was very nicely done
it's like the only one that's ever done
it this way oh no um one thing that I
did like about it that to me I'm not
used to seeing is that excuse me a lot
of times you'll have where it's not the
main characters its background
characters that kind of you know take
over the forefront and all that stuff
what I like about this time is these are
two characters you've never met before
like that's taking a chance like we
already saw an episode with LSP and that
did not work very well this is one where
it's two characters you've never met
before that they tossed into the main
story unless taking a chance and I
thought it paid off very well and Naruto
said boy sorry it's like a rapper
the kitchen wrapper yeah mellow music
scream oh you're mocking me but I do
like how they chose characters you
wouldn't expect and yeah I like the fact
that they didn't talk very much and they
played well off from each other
literally and they did play together
yeah um like oh no my favorite is where
he's using his the snow golem is using
his fingers and the puppies so happy
licks one it just melts operas like oh
oh the puppy looks terrified like he's
gonna get beaten there's like no no no
it's okay sweater look haha
like as Jake said don't they hate each
other you know at the Emily's these two
races apparently hate each other and I
thought it was kind of nice to the hole
and it's been done before the hole you
find a baby of a different race or
species or whatever you no matter what
it is and that kind of transcends all
things taking care of something younger
and something that's more innocent than
you are it doesn't matter where it comes
from it's still this desire to take care
of it I think this is a good example of
that and it was very nicely done plus
it's got my favorite team verdict we're
finding and even in this Lee Beesley
I really laughed hard when I realized
that Armour was never gonna move nice
things are burn because I saw it oh this
is fine there's this big thing going on
the background we're not gonna see it
but you realize it's never really going
on he's just stuck in that suit
well I love because he's like he's in
the armor he's like you guys wouldn't be
attached you guys wouldn't be doing what
you're doing if you were in my position
and Finn goes yeah but you would be
doing what we're doing if you were in
our position yeah and he's like you're
right so I bet you Jerry well I I agree
with both of you of course it's
wonderful but I think I don't know and
maybe it's just me but part of the
reason that I love it not just because
of the heartwarming little oh how cute
scene and it was you guys this was kind
of like crazy was like for me a cross
between mr. bean
and Happy Tree Friends I mean how many
will bloody Revere's Happy Tree Friends
no golem I mean with the tree in the eye
and everything he does have a crazy
dream and it was like one minute I was
like oh my god it's kind of like mr.
bean because it's kind of cute and then
like the tree trunk in the eyeball or or
even that whole scene with the finger
where it pops off and his head pops off
and another one comes on at all I was
like this is Happy Tree Friends and hey
I think it works because it gave you a
little bit or it gave me a little bit of
breather from the all it's really cute
it's really sweet this story that we've
done before
how wonderful its it is and it's great
but it's nice to kind of break it up a
little bit even that god damn bird
alarm clock when there's any alarm clock
I know what she's talking about like
this tick reaction went very good yeah
whatever I hear that like my eye
twitches cuz I sound I've actually I've
gone on that way to get alarm clocks
that do not have that sound because I
hate it so much because I always think
it's getting up for school it's just
like pee were sound in the world so it's
very gratifying when the dog the birds
react she's like ah what you know what
you were saying there with you know the
the snow gongqing burned off and chopped
up and stuff like that I think now he's
that funny but it helps with the
connection because you show it's like
this thing is hurting him but he's still
going to look after I'm he still cuz he
knows he doesn't know any bear and stuff
and even waste climbing in the mountain
or the volcano whatever and he's melting
and he's he's up down there he's like
I'm still gonna brave it I'm still gonna
do it you know cuz they do have that
connection and if anything it's it shows
a doesn't know any bears we has to look
out from even more and he'll sort of
brave the pain that he's gonna go
through for it so on top of it being
funny there's also bad going on yes um
the only other thing I'll say is that I
you know at the very
and if you have to tell me you like this
ended with Finn kissing the Ice King
thank you it's a legitimate heartfelt
seed I you know it's also funny don't
get me wrong but it's a legitimate
heartfelt seed
I've got outcome I am time I jump in the
shower gets it was so stupid but there
is a like I said it's because of how
well the story worked and it was paced
and it worked up to that and just on top
of that I think there's something nice
about especially with this show because
I think the show does kind of have fun
with kind of generals and stuff like
that and you know whatever whatever you
want to do if you're masculine you wanna
do feminine things by view or feminine
might be masking the things about I
don't care there's this great big thing
about like you know for years women have
tried to do a we can do what men can do
and they've worked their way and it's
wonderful and now there's kind of this
thing where it's like men trying to come
on honey
don't be like but but now there's sort
of this thing where it's like it's
trying to work the other way to where
it's like you know men can do stuff that
can be kind of feminine or emotional or
feeling and there's still sort of this
you know whoa what's wrong with you you
know man the man or whatever and it's
it's nice that show can actually you
know sort of do this and it's warranted
it doesn't feel forced or fail yeah it
feels like hey we're not trying to make
him you know like make any big stand
here we're just doing something it feels
very natural and it works you know and
like I say it doesn't feel shoved in
your face or anything so I liked it it's
the same thing with like the the Fionna
and cake episode where it's just like it
feels very natural it doesn't feel like
this is weird you know or if it is where
it's a good kind of way here you know
everything in the show is weird but in
this world it feels very natural so I
just like that I thought that was a very
legit moment so anything else I felt all
warm and fuzzy frightening because
because I felt so bad I've been saying
from the beginning he just needs a
friend it was kind of nice seeing him
again
friend it was so nice to finally see him
get just that tiny
validation after those other episodes
they were like so depressing Yin even
the legend caught me male 1 you know
it's kind of depressing and that you're
just watching Jake slowly die Ice King
yes thank you come on baby a little
something a little uplifting so yeah no
I feel lucky this would be our Christmas
guys smile damn you